what's going on reject nation we are going to
watch today spider-man no way home behind the
scenes featurette and some new posters
to look at too before we go into that i
want to give a special thank you to today's
sponsor a sponsor that we have been wanting
to work with for the longest time and that is
display tell them about display guys display
makes these durable metal art prints that are
super easy to install display and swap out
they've got more than a million designs in
their store including original art as well
as some of our favorite ips like marvel
star wars dc and so much more than that
and not only are the designs great we'll make them
especially awesome coming from a guy who's had to
put pins and a lot of favorite posters of his or
just use that whole little scotch tape thing where
you double-sided you don't need any power tools
to install them thanks to displate's magnet base
mounting system which takes only about 20
seconds to install we just hung this awesome
spider-man design and i cannot wait to continue
growing our collection and now is a great time
to start your own collection because display
ships to over 56 countries and only about
four to five business days so hit our special
link in the description box to save yourself 23
on your first one or two displays or 27 when
you grab three or more by supporting them you're
supporting the channel and there's a support this
is so cyclical so do it now let's watch this video
we're going to lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're going to jump off
now it's just so funny
yeah yeah dude 20 minutes
oh they're gonna be great
i gotta find the easter eggs for you that's crazy
they look like they really mess around a lot
god i want it history it's great to see that
footage in high def over here man give it to me
wow that's crazy you know i don't really watch
behind the scenes on blu-rays for some reason
i think it's because like many many years ago when
christian bale was doing behind the scenes for
batman begins he was like i feel like some of that
ruins the mystique and the magic of movie making
and i'm like you know what christian
bale you're right and then i just
avoid it even though i watch it whenever they
go up on youtube but i feel like i'm going
to be absorbing a lot of this maybe we can
react to some of it here on the channel man
i mean to see all this historical stuff but i
heard there's some new posters that were released
that's what was going trending on twitter so i
wanted to take a look at those really fast before
we talk a little bit more about this all you
gotta do is go to twitter and find that hashtag
no way yes that's not a photoshop here we
go again it looks like a photoshop but i'm
gonna just say it's real my lesson okay yeah
according to variety they actually did this
for real for the pro bow oh that's cool they
they really that is like 100 accurate almost
it's a little it's a little more chillax helen's
doing two nah that's not a hundred percent not a
hundred percent but still looks pretty great is
there anything else okay looks like we got some
leak photos here yeah they're not high quality
man it is nuts we're actually gonna get promo
posters of just the three of them like they're
actual faces on there that you could purchase
like being in a time capsule where all of a sudden
like some alternate universe advertising is about
to drop now that yeah the cat's out of the bag oh
wow we got to get these framed or something like
that display get on it would you people just coat
every wall with one spider-man each and then the
fourth wall all three this is so cool because
like when you're looking at the footage for
for what they did here to know that they're
capturing all that and that's like a lot of the
stuff that i feel like a lot of us really want to
eat up you know when you think about the kind of
year maybe two years that we were all going
through wanting to just see any little snippet
we could spiderman no way home now to be getting
that really fulfilled with the magic and the
journey behind it and a lot of that real behind
the scenes interaction of what it was like on set
because we've got all these interviews with these
guys where you get all these stories with them and
yet we don't have any of the footage of them just
hanging out so we're gonna watch those stories
come to life and now on that behind the scenes it
looks like we're going to be getting actual behind
the scenes footage of them coming to life and some
real quality interviews with andrew garfield and
toby mcguire included in there i've never been
so hyped for a behind-the-scenes footage thing
ever to be unveiled for a blu-ray before because
of the amount of secrecy surrounding this and now
the secrets are all going to be coming out of the
bag in more ways than we ever realized you know
well it makes me wonder now too because you know
i mean these industries thrive on re-releasability
and content being uncovered over the years and
this seems like a prime opportunity to release
like the most ultimate compendium of yeah like
behind the scenes footage production notes all
that stuff and they said in the ad 20 minutes of
the extra other two spider-man like what what else
made it from the cutting room floor to the blu-ray
and and what else maybe from like rewrites and
stuff like that might be included because you know
i mean it seems like this movie especially was
rewritten and tweaked all throughout the process
it's one of those things where yeah it'll be super
fun and super immediately nostalgic to revisit
all those moments and see behind the curtain
but also yeah what did we miss and what other
potential flavors are there coming from these
guys it does feel like one of the few historical
moments of a home video release where everyone's
gonna be paying attention and everyone's gonna
be scouring all the different features and stuff
like that and really trying to figure out yeah
how did they bring this all together what's the
story behind it and it's funny i was talking to
a friend of mine last night who makes features
for blu-rays and stuff like that part of what he
you know approaches it with and was talking about
was the human element getting all the people
together to share the stories and i feel like
that's what's going to be the most exciting about
this is everybody getting to behold just what
it's like it's already been dazzling people in
these interviews that you know toby maguire and
andrew garfield have finally been able to do
it i feel like that is only going to increase
tenfold seeing the environment on set and getting
everybody's yeah story and enthusiasm behind
it because it does seem like one of the biggest
passion projects ever made and also this is a side
note here i've always liked zendaya so she was a
fine mj within the past two weeks i have seen all
of euphoria i just started from episode one and
i couldn't stop it and i am all caught up and i
don't know what this mysterious tom holland cameo
is that people said they think they spotted him
but i'm like i'd i'd look for it i couldn't
find it but the fact that i was seeing like
someone zendaya back there now too i'm actually
really excited to see more footage of her because
obviously she could act i didn't know how well
she could have like she is phenomenal in that
show beyond phenomenal so i'm like man you got to
give her more screw time in the next spider-man
movie especially knowing just how much more
fame she's gathered just from that show alone
and so to see her here and then i think those
rumors about tom holland and her going to house
together were false according to tom holland i saw
some little thumbnail about him saying it'll be on
the demonstration it'll be on the bed and then
purchasing their home yeah going through escrow
it's going to be really informative if
you're looking to buy a home you should
really pick up the spiderman all right guys
well are you gonna buy spider-man no way home
leave your thoughts down below hopefully we can
get away with reacting to some of this we've done
a lot of blocks lately already things so that
it'll be it'd be cool if you get some of this
up guys subscribe leave a like thank you again
to display for sponsoring this video once you've
got some great posters i got we've got a few
more to hang as well we'll catch you guys soon
you